every time you take your socks off
safety pin them together at the top and
then throw them in the hamper they stay
pinned together through the wash and dry
cycle so you don't end up losing one in
the process how much time do you think I
have in my life do you think I have an
extra 47 hours a week that I could pen
that I can carve out to sit there safety
pinning socks yes that's how long it
would take 47 hours I've decided so I'm
gonna have like in my closet just a
little uh tray of safety pins I don't
have time for that okay no one has time
for that if I have a sock bag I can
throw them in a sock bag that I can do
because I can do that whole thing I can
do that in one second but the safety pin
I gotta make sure I have a stock of
safety pins I've got to pin them
together it's this is a long process
there's the risk involved that I that I
could you know prick my finger get blood
on the socks